Hello, the internet.
I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys
and we've had a lot of
requests by you, for drums.
Yeah, I got my hands on a
Secondhand war drum pretty much.
It's massive, big old
bass drum and a cymbal.
And we gonna film in slow motion
to see the frequency moving through them.
And maybe we'll art it up a little bit.
Yeah.
Got some different color powder paints,
put some liquids on there,
see what all it looks like.
Yeah.
So should we see what we can drum up.
From black to black?
No, maybe like a couple of inches in,
from black to black.
So, like wider channels of more color?
Yeah.
So like this?
Okay.
A bit of that on there.
Bloody hell. That orange is mental.
so fine.
It's the finest powder
paint I've seen in my life.
Straight from the bag on that one.
Straight from the bag.
.
Okay.
So we'll start our
filming at 1000 fps in 4K.
It should look top of the morning.
Bloody lovely.
Look at that.
That is pruh.
So I wanna see it from the top down.
But it's all immediately gonna flat focus.
I'm gonna focus it, sort of predicatively.
Let's say it goes- this the top of it,
that's where it like
finishes, so maybe like here?
Maybe here?
Yeah.
Go for it.
Ready?
Lovely.
Cool.
It looks cool.
Well, that is a really cool
gradient of colors there,
look at it.
So hit it from one side and we'll see
if we can see the shockwave travel.
Very good.
All right.
I wanna see this slightly faster
so switch the resolution to HD,
which will give us about 2000 FPS.
So we've got a lot of good
footage from hitting it
on the top of the drum,
so we're gonna try and
we'll see what it looks like
hitting it from the
underneath of the membrane.
I imagine it'll look very different.
Cause the minute the membrane's
doing all the work whereas if-
I feel like this one,
what we've done so far,
the vibration clicks it all up.
This one, the impact will click it up.
And so it will be centered on one point,
where I hit basically.
Oh flip.
Oh God.
Scary?
Just really, really bright.
It's like magnifying the sun in your eyes.
Can you give me your sunglasses?
They're by the back door.
look up.
There you go.
Ah beat.
What an interesting problem to have,
I didn't think this was gonna be-
So much better.
An obstacle in filming this video.
I didn't predict this either.
Bloody hell.
That was way higher.
Didn't it?
Yeah.
It went like in the lens.
It's very different.
I wannna try filming it from further back,
with the slower camera.
But I think what you
should do is just make,
cause you can only hit
one spot, make one mound,
but layer all the colors
on top of each other.
Oh, okay.
Just a big pile of all the
different colors in the middle.
Yeah.
The reset time on this one,
not too bad.
How much do you want, paint?
I'd say, you know like the egg
in an egg McMuffin.
Yeah.
About that size.
Okay, relative to the
rest of the McMuffin.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
Do you mean including bread or?
No no, just the egg part of the muffin.
Okay.
I understand.
You want a cheat?
You might be better off just
the other bottom of a cup,
stacking it and take the cup off.
I don't like the idea
because you've thought of it.
That's the purple.
Went into my face.
Looks nice and your face,
look at his haircut.
All right.
Drum look good.
Let's move onto cymbal and stick
that white card you got right behind you.
Let's see what it looks like.
Okay, cool.
I like that a lot better
than random jungle.
You see the colors
better, I suppose as well.
Yeah.
Alright.
So we've moved over to the shed
cause that's still in the sun
and we'll actually try paint
on the white background
this time, cause we forgot.
I forgot.
Well Dan, I think that was some
lovely looking footage.
I'm actually a bit- I don't
have a 4K TV to watch it on,
but hopefully some of you do
and let me know how it was,
tweet it to me or something.
So I can't- your hair looks
stupid, it's ridiculous.
You got me. You've actually .
It's very rare that I'm
the one who gets messy.
I'm actually less messy somehow.
We can't be having that,
we have to do something about that.
Be sure to follow us on Twitter,
buy a shirt, have one of them
and also subscribe to the second channel
where there'll be behind the scenes stuff.
Actually devastated
that I'm the messy one.
You should go and clean yourself up.
Gonna just-
Special thanks to Newegg and WD
for sending me these two NAS drives.
Basically 48 terabytes
of hard drive storage
that I can access over my network.
The Phantom cameras
shoot around 16 gigabytes
per real time second.
So, as you can imagine,
I'm constantly in need
of additional hard drive space.
So this really helps me out.
There's a link to them in the description
if you're interested.